freunde der sonne manche von euch wissen
dass ich normalerweise gar kein alkohol
trinke und im laufe dieses videos werde
die auch verstehen warum
[Musik]
kennt ihr vielleicht das gerücht dass
asiaten kein alkohol vertragen
das ist kein rassistisches klischee das
ist einfach die wahrheit wenn circa 36
prozent der südostasiatischen dazu
gehören auch vietnamesen wie ich können
alkohol nicht richtig abbauen also das
trifft auch manchmal auch nicht asiaten
zu aber in asien ist das phänomen sehr
weit verbreitet ich habe mir hier ca 100
milliliter weisswein eingeschenkt um
euch zu demonstrieren was genau passiert
wenn asiaten alkohol trinken alles für
die wissenschaft prost ist es übrigens
nach einem meter und gott da ich dieses
klar es war nicht einfach abziehen kann
weil ich sonst alles hier voll kurzen
würde haben wir noch genug zeit in der
ich euch erklären kann was genau
chemischen asiaten vor sich geht wenn
sie alkohol trinken und um mich selbst
werden wir keine grafik einen blenden
sondern nicht werde alles erklärende
hier auf diesem blog selbst mal was
natürlich im laufe des videos immer
schwieriger werden wird fangen wir doch
vielleicht erst man damit an was mit
normalen menschen passiert wenn sie
alkohol trinken
[Musik]
das wort alkohol im alltagsgebrauch
steht für einen bestimmten alkohol
ethanol da sieht so aus dieser gruppe
ist das was alkohol ausmacht und ein
alko mit zwei c atomen ist ethanol
ethanol
ethanol ist nicht nur mega schädlich wie
die leber man kann ab einer blut
konzentration von drei promille auch
schon mal sterben wenn man glück hat
kommt man vorher alles aus wenn man pech
hat erstickt man seine eigenen kurze war
man gerade bewusstlos ist ansonsten kann
man tod durch alkoholvergiftung auch
vermeiden indem man sich den magen
auspumpen lässt bestimmt auch ein ganz
angenehmer eingriff alkohols also
eine super droge leuten ganz heiße
freunde der sonne
ich weiß jetzt nicht genau wie viel ich
getrunken habe seit die aufnahme
gestoppt hat aber mein akku war leer und
ich habe nichts davon gemerkt habe ich
gerade ganz viel erklärt und es wurde
nicht aufgenommen
ich habe mir noch meinen zettel liegen
momentan ist nicht das einzige problem
denn ethanol wird im körper umgewandelt
zu acetaldehyd mithilfe das stimmt ja
nicht so dass ich das noch mal auch
nicht die chemische reaktion verläuft
mit hilfe eines enzyms namens adhs summe
sind sogenannte katalysator das heißt
enzyme hilfe einer chemischen reaktion
schneller zu verlaufen
die ohne dieses enzym so gut wie nicht
oder nur sehr langsam verlaufen würde
okay also enzyme wichtig erzählt alle
hübsch ist schlecht agiert ist ein
sogenanntes mutter gehen es verändert
deine generell lehne eine dna und bringt
auch noch sämtliche andere
krebserregende effekte möglich
acetaldehyd schlecht das acetaldehyd
wird weiterhin abgebaut zu essigsäure
beziehungsweise zutaten also genau
genommen den salzen der essigsäure aber
egal das ist der grund warum man nach
einer durchzechten nacht übersäuert ist
bzw
nach einem nachmittag wo manchen stau
videos aufnimmt
diese chemische reaktion verläuft auch
mit hilfe eines enzyms namensschilder
zwei aldehyd dehydrogenase allerdings
die nase 2
diese enzyme ist wie gesagt da capo
seite ohne sie ohne dieses enzym kann
diese reaktion nur sehr lang
verlaufen und es erzählt aufgebaut aus
proteinen und bei menschen wie nie ist
in diesem großen proteinen eine einzige
aminosäure vertauscht und aufgrund
dieser einst einen abgrund aufgrund
dieser ein vertauschen aminosäure
funktioniert das nicht mehr
das heißt bei mir wenn ich auch nur
wenig trinke ist die konzentration von
acetaldehyd in meinem körper viel höher
als bei menschen bei denen das erzählt
erhöht direkt wieder abgebaut wird so
[Applaus]
das update führt jedenfalls neben den
dna veränderungen und dergleichen zu
herzrasen übelkeit und dem so genannten
flash sind rom
das heißt man hier droht ich weiß nicht
ob ich bin ich rot jedenfalls asiaten
haben immer eine extrem hohes level an
az aldehyd intus
was außerdem recht lange anhält weil
dieses az also wie gesagt nur sehr
langsam abgebaut wird das heißt sie
haben werden sehr schnell betrunken und
bleiben auch recht lange betrunken
jedenfalls deswegen trinke ich auch kein
alkohol aus 100 liter weißwein für schön
schlau
[Musik]
geschafft also diese ganze situation
hier ich bin mega roth mir ist sehr
heißen hier ist ein bisschen schlecht
herzrasen ja nichts desto trotz dieser
session fleisch sind rum muss man
letztendlich als schutz ansehen und so
sehen das viele experten aus dingen
wegen dieser ganzen situation hier bin
ich über uns dazu in der lage größere
menge an alkohol zu mir zu nehmen
hinzu kommt dass al ko auch richtig
geschmeckt wenn man nicht die
gelegenheit hat sich das mit der zeit
langsam an zu gewöhnen und sich rein
samsung war ganz ehrlich alkohol
schmeckt einfach nach lösungsmittel es
tut mir leid es ist einfach so wie ihr
vertrag tier alkohol ich gehe davon aus
besser als ich aber schreibt in die
kommentare
zusammen mit euren fragen die gerne mal
in einem video beantwortet hätte sie
sehen uns nächste woche nochmals
treffsicher